ciao a tutti bentornati una nuova
puntata di mi rassegno stampa in questo
caso del mese di aprile andiamo subito a
raccontare gli eventi salienti di questo
mese
l'orrore sull'attore era una incornata
nell'arena il toro si eccita e la monta
qui possiamo vedere il video della
giovane professionista possiamo dire
ecco seguendo quello che è il mood dei
tg che vedete durante l'ora di pranzo
che in un certo senso la torre era na na
se l'è cercata
molto probabilmente indossava una
minigonna una mini mini mini mini mini
mini con questa è una notiziona perché a
post cc parla di elisa della nostra cara
e l'izoard di che stira le camicie il
venerdì sera un venerdì sera da leoni ha
scritto nella didascalia sotto alla foto
su instagram gli utenti fortunatissimo
il signor salvini elisa ti prego io
spero che tu riesca anche ad abbottonare
queste camicie perché altrimenti non
saprei come potrebbe fare salvini a
metterselo o magari cuci degli strappi
sopra i 200 celle boys
ok cento lega boys commenti memorabili
mi regala un sogno è uscito un articolo
ma gesù cristo era un bonazzo andiamo a
leggere sette volti un intruso ci fanno
vedere un sacco di di boni alessandro
che commenta una leggenda narra che fu
il primo tronista di maria
gianluca invece uomini e madonne andiamo
avanti beyonce o in questo periodo c'è
stato il coach ella è affatto una cosa
veramente unica riunito e le destiny's
child
tutte quante le donne e gay del mondo
sono impazziti davanti alla notizia è
stato effettivamente un evento che ha
fatto molto molto molto parlare di sé
se non fosse che la notizia subito dopo
è beyoncé cade rovinosamente sul palco
insieme alla sorella solange arriviamo
direttamente al punto in cui la cantante
mentre abbraccia la storia
cade per terra questo qui ci vuole far
ricordare una cosa è un'amara metafora
della vita non importa che tu abbia
riunito le destiny's child non importa
che abbiano parlato di te per giorni e
giorni la vita trova sempre un modo per
metterti roma barcellona o questa che è
stata una notizia meravigliosa è
arrivata persino bene e parla di calcio
impresa incredibile all'olimpico
giallorossi in semifinali di champions
league dovevano fare tre a zero per
riuscire a passare hanno fatto tre a
zero e stata una partita epica che ha
riunito tutta quanta la tifoseria
italiana ho visto i miei fratelli
laziali e juventini che comunque hanno
goduto per questa squadra avrei voluto
anch'io essere fra fra loro a gioire e
godere delle p cita di questo match
il problema è che mi occupo di palle
diverse parliamo però ancora di calcio
comunque all'interno di questo mese ha
fatto molto parlare di calcio buffon
dopo la partita uno che si comporta così
al posto del cuore a un bidone
dell'immondizia alle significative
parole del portiere bianconero
sull'arbitro inglese
al termine di real madrid juventus se ha
detto al posto del cuore a un video
nell'intima il mio ex per caso fa
l'arbitro può elezioni politiche e
ancora non
non abbiamo un governo cosa può
succedere adesso se qualcuno di voi ha
avuto modo di vedere the walking dead
iniziate a fare scorte devo dire anche
un'altra cosa io non sono mai stato
meglio in italia dopo vent'anni i
protagonisti di dawson's creek di nuovo
insieme qui c'è una foto dei quattro
protagonisti c'è dawson pesi e la
[ __ ] come si chiamava johanna agen e
johanna possa dire la cosa ma che fine
ha fatto dawson e secondo me aspettava
il suo momento per poter riuscire
finalmente sotto i riflettori questa la
sua canzone possiamo vederlo
la prossima occasione si presenterà fra
altri dieci anni con il trentesimo di
dawson's creek un fatto di cronaca
avvenuto nella laziale sente l'odore e
ruba furgone pieno di pizzette call
della pizzette romane si sa sono
irresistibili dice questo articolo
soprattutto per un uomo di castelnuovo
di porto che ha sentito il profumo di
pizzette appena appena sfornate e
caricate suo furgone ha deciso di rubare
furgone e il 7 l'uomo non è stato ancora
trovato fortunatamente anche perché da
castelnuovo di porto e si è spostato a
milano e mi sta parlando in questo
esatto momento parliamo di cibo e
continuiamo a rimanere nel food la
comunità ebraica italiana sta discutendo
molto di carciofi hanno molto tempo
libero quelli della comunità ebraica
italiana
cosa è successo i rabbinato centrali di
israele ha deciso che i carciofi alla
giudia non sono conoscere perché
all'interno delle foglie potrebbero
essere presenti degli insetti o dei
vermi e i vermi non sono conoscerla
un'occasione in più per praticare
l'ateismo forsennato continuiamo con una
notizia che a me ha straziato
purtroppo non si può sempre parlare di
cose divertenti ma parliamo invece di
andrea d'amante che conferma l'addio
aggiunto
de lellis è un momento difficile ora
dopo l'annuncio l'ex gieffina ci siamo
lasciati
arriva la versione dell'ex tronista
voglio capire che modo possa aggiungere
al ci siamo lasciati però sempre
ovviamente via social alcuni alcuni
meccanismi ormai non funzionano più
i due erano due ingranaggi a quanto pare
buona notizia che tocca i bambini i
vostri figli ragazzi cicciobello si è
ammalato ma il morbillo non è
assolutamente un gioco
il celebre bambolotto a dei puntini
rossi che le bambine fanno scomparire
per magia con salviettine e certini il
bambolotto è stato lanciato sui social
il primo aprile e non pochi hanno
sospettato lo scherzo come finalità di
marketing invece il cicciobello morbilli
no esiste davvero
scusate ma non è tipo di cattivissimo
gusto la cosa di questo tipo ma allora a
questo punto attendiamo lo so
cicciobello sieropositivo cicciobello
con busta da abbandonare in un bidone
della spazzatura o questa è una storia
brutta e altri invece ci hanno dato
tanta gioia
noi kardashian traditela fidanzato
tristan thompson mentre lei ormai al
nono mese di gravidanza e sta per dare
alla luce la loro bambina
no guarda qua aveva due milioni e
seicento like di su insta camera amore
vero
il sex tape rimosso nel giro di poche
ore i siti continuano ad aggiornarsi con
ulteriori notizie e dettagli sulla
vicenda sempre tms rivela che la donna
che sosteneva di essere quella con cui
thomson ha trascorso una notte avrebbe
pubblicato e poi rimosso un sex tape su
instagram stories su instagram storiche
[Risate]
un lutto enorme per il mondo della
musica è quello di abissi amici fatemi
sapere questo dove si mette l'accento e
come si presenta lo spelling in pochi
anni era diventato una star
internazionale ma lui era quello lì e mi
dispiace in pochi anni era diventato una
star internazionale un giovanissimo
artista richiesto dei più grandi nomi
della scena musicale amici
l'unica cosa che posso dire a questo
punto è vai e insegna agli angeli a
ballare
l'elettronica svedese mi spiace un sacco
anche perché in tutto questo continuiamo
e passiamo a quelli che sono invece i
vivi del del mese c'è chi tiene botta
nonostante tutto pippo baudo
abbiamo anche rita pavone rocco hunt e
roberto saviano
a questo punto chiudiamo questo
appuntamento del mese con uno spunto di
riflessione per tutti quanti una frase
un tempo per vedere un culo dove visse
costare una mutanda
adesso per vedere una mutanda davis
costare un culo
a presto